but sometimes I'll I'll overinflate the
figures maybe I I'll say the the referb
is maybe going to cost 30 grand oh man I
thought for a minute you meant over
inflight the gdv that wouldn't be very
smart so when you say you mean be super
conservative about things like the
referb cost yeah yeah so why do you do
that what if the refund was going to be
40 why would you say it's going to be 50
under promise and overd deliver I guess
bang yeah yeah and that prevents refunds
yep yep 100% because if you said the
refund is going to be 48 and it's
actually going to be 42 mhm the
Investor's going to go out and go well
you said 40 now it's whereas if you do
it the other way around you say it's
going to be 40 and then it's actually 30
or 35 they're going to be like well that
was my finders fee paid for now they're
going to be your biggest fan now they're
going to Rave about you now they're
going to pass you referrals